alors en direct avec nous le pdg d'air
france jacques friedmann monsieur merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés laurent
boussier monsieur friedman vous entendez
le bourget vous nous entendez roissy
plutôt se découvrent qu'il s'agit de
roissy oui parce que sean williams
semblait parfait c'est laurent la part
luigi à côté de moi monsieur friedman
voilà maintenant on a le temps tout va
bien oui monsieur friedman première
question quel est l'intérêt cet appareil
pour vous en france
à écouter c'est un intérêt considérable
parce que l'airbus 320 cet accord le
premier avion de renouvellement de
modernisation de notre flotte
c'est l'entrée dans notre flotte un des
avions les plus performants très moderne
et compétitif et qui à mon avis donnera
une très grande satisfaction l'ensemble
de nos passagers c'est donc un grand
jour pour air france que l'entrée de l'a
320 se fait de mal je vais essayer
d'aller au delà de l'arrivée de ce
simple avion 1992 l'europe le grand
marché unique européen
il y a des dizaines de compagnies qui
vont venir en france prendre vous
prendre des passagers que comptez vous
faire pour empêcher ça et pour vous même
prendre des parts de marché en europe
mais on n'a pas tant lui 1993 j'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure que depuis deux
ans nous avions ouvert 64 destinations
nouvelles sur l'europe
par conséquent ce que nous souhaitons
c'est pouvoir couvrir le plus possible
le marché européen et nous comptons
beaucoup sur l'a320 qui va remplacer les
anciens à 727 en tout cas les premiers
qui ont été livrées à peu près 20 ans et
qui nous permettront par conséquent de
d'assurer dans un un niveau de confort
le meilleur possible
toutes ces liaisons et à mon avis qu une
qualité de services une régularité et un
confort tout à fait que friedman quel
est l'intérêt pour le consommateur pour
le voyageur de cet appareil
et bien c'est un c'est un avion qui
d'abord est plus confortable c'est à
dire où par exemple la le volume
intérieur est un petit peu plus large
que celui des avions antérieurs
c'est un avion où il est plus facile de
circuler à l'intérieur c'est un avion ou
le problème de la sonorisation c'est à
dire l'absence de bruit a été tout à
fait soigner c'est un avion enfin où les
pour les bagages c'est à dire pour tout
ce qui est homme d'affaires toutes les
personnes qui utilisent quotidiennement
soit en avion
à mon avis le confort sera accrue
monsieur plenel moi je vais vous parler
prix parce que en fait ce qui intéresse
surtout les gens et surtout les gens qui
prennent l'avion peut souvent ce sont
les prix cet avion consomme on le sait
40% de moins de carburant que les avions
qu'il va remplacer
c'est vrai est-ce que c'est 40 % vont se
ressentir au niveau du billet écoutez je
sais pas si les 40 % vont se ressentir
au niveau du billet ce que je veux dire
c'est que nous n'avons pas attendu la
livraison de ce a320 pour essayer de
d'être plus compétitif et quand on
regarde l'évolution des prix du
transport aérien je crois que nous
sommes compétitifs nuls mais sont chaque
fois que nous pouvons nos prix au
profiter des passagers de l'eau de nos
clients ce que j'aurai également indiqué
c'est que en effet il consomme 40% le
mois que les anciens avions il faut
reconnaître également qui coûte plus
cher c'est à dire que nous remplacions
un vieil avion acheté il ya 20 ans par
un avion moderne et justement monsieur
friedman cet avion à votre avis
sera-t-il une arme pour affronter la
concurrence européenne et surtout le
marché unique de 1991
écoutez ça ne sera pas une arme ça sera
l'armé essentielle et c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai indiqué ce matin que
pour moi c'était non seulement
aujourd'hui le journée air france une
journée airbus mais c'est une journée
europe europe parce que ça sera l'avion
des lignes européennes qui nous
permettront de relier les principales
capitales les principales villes
d'europe entre l europe parce que c'est
à l'avion conçu par l'ensemble des
grands constructeurs aéronautiques
européens et en plus ça sera l'avion qui
sera prêt pour le marché de 1993 alors
quelles vont être les premières
destinations desservies par a320
première destination c'est le 18 avril
c'est paris düsseldorf berlin et après
nous
entre le 18 avril et le mois de novembre
nous assureront des liaisons avec rome
avec genève avec amsterdam avec nice et
avec unique avec les principales grandes
villes de l'europe des 12 voilà patricia
je voulais rajouter encore que le
prochain airbus a320 allait être livré à
british airways et qu'air france
recevrait dans cette année 88
quatre de ces avions merci merci
messieurs